oh my god
[Applause]
why jelly who came up with that as dis
disgusting
[Music]
hey it's sam fender and this is snap
wars north v south for lard bible we're
doing north east south because i'm from
the north and i'm in the south all the
time so let's have it let's see what
we'll go
oh
greggs what we call this um
you call that like a a shields dummy
because it's what what you give your kid
to shut up
sorry all the all the babies you just
see them in the pram
as always gotta be covered in it
amazing
as always getting stars
i already know i'm in a band like you
know you live in service stations you've
got to
deal with this stuff has this been miked
it's been mic'd on it
a snow contest
greg's every time here we go
[Music]
oh how where what is that jellied eels
that's like i thought that was only
inflate oliver twist and stuff like that
what
it's from
nah i'm still gonna eat it though
bush tucker trail yeah let's do it and a
pork pie i mean this is like this is
just no contest is it no one eats that
no one i've only been up for like half
an hour
it's literally it is jellied
oh mate
oh
no
no
that's lift and not
oh my god
[Applause]
why jelly who came up with that as
disgusting
there we go
there we go
i've been saved
i love pie the north has one again
whoa i've got to whack all the stuff on
it i've now i've never really
done the whole afternoon tea thing what
do you do do you get rid of that stuff
off the top i use like jam first and
cream was there like a real debate about
it yeah so the south is cream then jam
and then more north is jam than
clotted cream it doesn't make a hip of a
difference since we're in the south i'll
when in rome i'll do cream on the bottom
watch there'll be a load of northerners
in the comment section going trailer
he's lost his way
he's forgot where he's come from
oh that looks naughty though wait watch
this
north
south
man that's good people don't like
eggless cakes but i do
i do
i like it
i like the articles cake i don't like it
as much as i remember the scone won
massively there
is that piece pudding it is peaceful
and what is that
gentleman's relish oh spiced anchovy
relish
in the morning
i've never had peas pudding on a crack i
like
it's a real dividing thing because some
people prop i think it's disgusting
i love it it's i don't know i think it
just tastes like my childhood this stuff
however yeah i don't know how what is it
you got to take off the bit in the
middle
see it's it's northern proof
oh this is
oh
looks toxic-like
oh
what is that
that is lit in that leg what is that is
it just a smashed up anchovies oh peace
pudding knife as well
not
that's horrible that i mean i like
anchovies
but that's just like anchovies on roy
it's that
definitely the north one that again for
this game the north one
i'm going good
great content
all right then
um
where have i been
oh my life
this is so good like if i had a bit of
like a little bit of brie brie cracker
and a bit of
bali molly